so the you know the recording artist
Drake yes he did this kind of
interesting thing instead of doing a
press tour he made up a fake press tour
and released it yeah yeah he completely
he's been sharing these fake video clips
of interviews and performances and album
covers he hasn't actually done and then
he even put out a clip of me
interviewing him wow he edited himself
in to look like he was in our studio and
he's answering questions from me using
clips from a different interview
here's a Drake on the Howard Stern Show
the fake Howard Stern Show you said you
were open about porn what type of porn
are you watching what is your thing
top wow holy [ __ ] highest tier of top
givers that's really what I'm I say
consistently like on a daily basis tuned
into like right just really like those
are like the real superstars of the
world to me yeah
uh and What About Love
I mean could you ever commit to one
woman yeah yeah yeah be married you
could be married
oh yeah
I'm sure I could you know so anyway they
keep put together this whole thing and I
was like Jesus it sounds real like
whenever I have to promote something I
should have done hell whenever I have to
go visit my mother I wish I could do
this
I don't think she's gonna uh sit for
that but she might get away with it with
a press Drake did such a good job that
the news outlets are reporting on it as
if it's real they you know that's and
that's sort of the weird thing about our
lives now the video has 16 million views
and and Good Day Atlanta reported on the
Drake interview well certified lover boy
Drake is revealing whether he'd ever get
married over his career he's been linked
to a few different women but who've
never really seen him in a steady
relationship but in a candid interview
with Howard Stern Drake was asked if he
could ever commit to just one woman
I think that eventually once all this is
said and done for us and that addiction
of work and success and forward movement
is over I feel like we're all going to
need something real hoping it's not too
late okay but then like right now I feel
like I get into this habit of dating
like four or five women to make one
woman
what
not I cannot with that oh my goodness
okay well he does have a five-year-old
son so maybe maybe one day I I do like
Drake I just four to five women to make
one woman he just has a lot of growing
up oh wow okay I'm not against that we
have enough material from all the shows
we've done we could just do our whole
thing with you everybody yeah yeah
anybody we will how great is that though
and these ladies are mad at his fake
interview that's right yeah they're
gonna they're gonna protest them for
something he made up he goes yeah I have
four or five women that make up one
whole woman